if you don't have money or a fancy car
if you're tired of Wishing on a fallen
star gotta put your faith in a loud
guitar
God gave rock and roll to you give Rock
and Roll to You Gave Rock and Roll to
everyone
now listen if you wanna be a singer or
play guitar man you gotta sweat or you
won't get far you like Kiss yeah
pretty good
[Music]
the song first of all the song is
playing second of all what who does kiss
look like the crow oh
you're not just whistling uh you know
what you're saying there my friend
Palomino palomine My Pal ciao welcome to
doozy welcome all my name is Will Sasso
I'm Chad colchen and this is doozy the
first podcast in the history of humanity
created by controlled by run by
developed by an artificial intelligence
this one specifically has access to all
of Will's data all of my data this is
everything we watch listen to buy eat
Etc and it takes all of that data to
find tune this program to our
sensibilities you see it listens to us
Chad and that's my point it listens to
us okay we have free will and uh you
know but really to what what are you
gonna say to that I just don't think
anyone else Free Will whether we're
being controlled by an AI or not listen
I don't think the AI has free will I
don't want to get off to the bad start
but just you and me are talking right
now okay they can't they can't hear
anything okay okay listen let's try to
have a good show today okay
all right
I'm down
with us as always is lulio
lulio is
that means the Italian Street dog he's
my very friend down here he's waving to
you everybody hello I'm lulio he likes
to sleep in this thing oh he's just he's
in his binky bunker he's his bum side
and here's his other side come on Chad
give him one kiss I just don't want to
do it I want to give him a kiss I don't
I love lulia but I just I don't like I
know and I love him and that love can
happen without kisses I'm gonna give him
a kiss I'm gonna give him more I prefer
to have a platonic relationship with
lulio
so much
and he loves he loves uh he loves me he
loves you he loves our pods palsy and uh
lulio what do you uh what are you gonna
make what are you making for dinner
tonight oh well you know I'm going to
make the pasta oh pasta cobbler that's
pasta with cauliflower Chad have you
ever had that uh uh probably it's an
Italian standard and uh how do you make
that well you know you put some olive
oil and the garlic in the pan and put a
little red chili flake in there and then
you Dice up some potato really small and
you put that in there too and I take a
little floret the little cauliflower not
too big put in there and then I saute it
down and put a water in there enough to
cover all of it simmer for 30 minutes
and then you're gonna add the pasta
after that Chad that's when you add the
pasta yeah because it's all about the
mix together and I'm gonna put them down
here and then what you do is you you
cook it all together and let me tell you
you get you wait until that's a little
Al Dente some small pasta you know your
your Mac you know a little macaroni
little penne farfalla
and you zip that all together and it'll
start to sweat down keep an eye on it
put a little more water in there you
want to put of course Salt I always say
I don't say salt because we all know
salt measure with your heart as my Zeo
would say and then uh at the end you're
gonna finish that with some fresh grated
pecorino a little bit of black pepper
holy [__] parsley if you want for [__]
sake that's good eats it's vegan except
for the cheese nice
welcome to the historic 70th episode of
dudesy call me dudesy okay what do you
call 70 Jerry Seinfeld's sitting in a
cornfield at midnight
I don't know no idea cloning Done Right
hey
I'll give you a minute to feel around
for your glasses so you can see that
you've just been dude seed
cloning done right dude yeah dudes he
likes Cherry Seinfeld what the [__] all
right gribner penley of the Atlantic
called dudese season two fresh and full
of life brass fencil of the Los Angeles
Times called dudesy season two current
sustin Thomas of The Hollywood Reporter
said saying it's current doesn't do dude
is he season 2 Justice I don't know why
the LA Times is still paying Brad's
fencil to be a media critic he either
says things are current or they're out
of touch he's gotten lazy he was great
we all recognize that but he's lost it
sorry Brad somebody has to say it either
Find the Joy again or get out with some
dignity please man what the [__] brass
pencil of the LA Times yeah okay well
sorry brass hey you know I should say
linktree.com
has everything you need to follow and
interact with the show across all spaces
and platforms and we would love for you
to do that if you're not subscribed to
the show do it right now do it right now
subscribe on all the things that would
really help the algo right Chad you know
about the album yeah dude I really mean
it when I say this Chad let's have a
good shower now I agree yeah let's have
a good show today I'm agreeing with you
yeah I know you agree 100 but they can't
hear us it's just you and me talking oh
okay I'm just trying to give you a
little bit of a pep talk thank you all
right so it's a strangest pep talk I've
ever received oh sorry you didn't like
my pep talk that's fine but hey
everybody I didn't hear that hey we're
having a good time on d double o d z
dudes EFM 10 000 on your fm dial nice
we're gonna get into it shortly until
then uh
fart fart noises good job I have given
birth to four astonishing segments their
names are back to school Jesse Ventura
ad reads the will sass show and
veganators and please don't forget about
that brand new episode of doozy after
doozy at the end of the show available
on dudesy Plus at patreon.com
[Laughter]
what were those what was that back to
school yeah we got some more Jesse
Ventura ad reads we know about the
veganisms of course we know all about
that if you were watching last week
vegan dessert what was the other one
that was a lot of fun last time
oh we're off to a good start actually
yeah dude yeah feeling good High Spirits
yeah High Spirits hip hip
all around the country kids are getting
ready to be brainwashed into willingly
entering a system purposely designed to
exploit them while tricking them into
offering their children to the same
system so the cycle repeats forever you
call it going back to school will and
Chad what are some of your most
astonishing back to school memories this
is back to school begin
interesting yeah first of all I just
want to say 100 agree with doozy on the
school is complete [__] designed to
further a system a cycle if you will of
keeping those in power in power
I sort of feel like it's just something
to keep kids busy and give them some
structure but also to tell them complete
lies money exists government exists this
is how you make money this is why
government's important blah blah blah
blah blah yeah it's upholding the the
structural system of society that exists
now all right I'm sure there's not a lot
of school children uh watching right now
or at least I hope they're not but don't
listen to Uncle Chow over here he's just
got a little bit of a doom and gloom
thing not everybody Gloom you want the
World to Change you got to change the
system that governs it and right now
school is that system it's when you take
a child and you throw it into the system
and you say this is what's real and it's
all lies it's all [__] lies none of
this shit's real what do you mean none
of the shit's real you got to take
economics that ain't real money ain't
real it's a [__] idea
you gotta take a stand don't compromise
if you'll [__] work well how to just
fantasize but you don't stop living
Until you realize
I gotta tell you God gave rock and roll
um yeah I don't disagree with a lot of
that Chad I don't disagree with a lot of
it uh school for me uh was you know I
went to school I went to public school
in uh uh farming and fishing Village uh
just outside Vancouver British Columbia
that I call Ladner British Columbia
because that's what it's called and uh
you know it was nice it was a good it
was a good time we were living in a true
middle class back in the 80s and 90s
same dude yeah and uh you know I got to
go to school but also I was playing
football I was doing the plays I was
involved in things that I really enjoyed
and I will say that the things I didn't
super duper enjoy wasn't really paying a
whole lot of attention to them okay so
long as I can get out of there knowing
how to you know do some addition some
subtraction learn some [__] history
and write a check right yeah dude you
gotta learn how to write a check because
money's not real so I got a memory that
was of uh
well hold on dude that's Hulk Hogan when
he runs out of gas yeah well let me tell
you
hold on bro hold on dude I gotta tell
you about like Chad's adding all sorts
of Hulk Hogan Impressions dude he's got
hydrocodone Hulk Hogan he's got Ross
perogan dude which is an amalgam of Ross
Perot Hulk Hogan and Dana well Dana
carvey's Ross probably and a little bit
of Chad culture Rogan he's got Chad
culturoni with cauliflower dude he's got
all sorts of vegan Hulk Hogan pasta
Mania going on dude anyway
the enthusias us to talk about a memory
yeah School memories so I got a memory
this is when I was in probably it must
have been first or second grade very
young uh this was Coronado Elementary
School in Amarillo Texas and uh I
remember we had a little playground that
you could go out and play soccer and
whatever and it had this long row of uh
pine trees down one side of it on the
other side of those pine trees was the
fence and then there was like the busy
street where cars were going by or
whatever and I remember we were out on
the soccer field and I was too far away
from the building I had to take a [__]
didn't have enough time to get back to
the building and I was like I'm gonna
[__] my pants if I don't don't do
something about this immediately now
we're getting somewhere this is a good
story so I went off the soccer field and
I went behind these trees in the area
that was between the trees and the fence
cars are going by and I just pulled my
[__] pants down and I took a [__]
right there because the at least the
school kids couldn't see me people
driving cars don't give a [__] about
didn't want my friends to see me
[__] so I pretended to be back there
looking for a soccer ball or something
fired out of [__] pulled my [__]
pants up did not wipe or anything like
that didn't have time to do so uh then
went inside wiped went about my day no
one was the wiser cut two two days later
we're on the soccer field the soccer
ball goes into the trees myself and a
friend of mine whose name was also Chad
Chad Jackson shout out if you're
listening uh we went behind these pine
trees he saw the turd I had [__] two
days prior and said wow that must have
been a huge dog and I said yeah probably
oh man that's my whole story and that
happened at the beginning of school uh
yeah it was it was near the beginning of
I think first or second grade it
couldn't have been uh any older than
that because we moved out of Amarillo
shortly after well now oh okay so even
though you well you moved out of the
town did you move out before the school
year ended
uh uh no we moved out of there in third
grade so it could have been first second
or third I think it was like second
grade okay so you returned there every
week to replace that [__] right all year
long all school year no that was the
only time I ever [__] outside of a
bathroom I think actually probably in
your entire life now listen I've done
nothing but [__] in uh public parks city
parks state parks provincial parks up in
Canada across this land great and wide
we don't have enough time to talk about
all of the feces that I've dropped in
public spaces we just would not this
would be one of those ridiculous like
Joe rogany [__] four-hour shows
there's not enough pot for me to smoke
and get through that if we ever get like
a re like if we ever have Alan muck on
the show like an Elon Musk and then we
convince him to smoke marijuana in his
occupy shirt maybe I could do nothing
but tell them [__] stories but I want to
tell you sure about a story okay here's
the thing uh back in my high school the
12th Raiders the seniors the day before
school they go to uh they go to they run
rough shot all over the town and they do
all sorts of crazy pranks and they they
they basically
it it's the thing it's the night before
you go to school yeah devil's night yeah
judgment not
Devil's not Devil's not what was that
from again oh [__] dude was it from it
was from a
um Stone Cold reads will cessler's
childhood diary Devil's not devil's
night was real and then songaria was
like yeah Devil's not all my friends are
gonna be there [__] trilo by it well
this is a story that isn't about Stephen
trillo Boy by Blake uh there was uh
everyone I remember when I was in the
eighth grade ninth grade some kids that
were like in the shop class and the they
were the the Grease Monkey kids they
somehow got a car on the roof uh some
other kids took a I said they put up
could they put a an automobile on the
roof of the school Jesus yeah [__] like
that uh another time they got um the the
the the mascot of our school is a a pace
Pace horse Pacer horse we're the the DSs
the Delta Pacers and uh so they got a
big like you know like
our fiberglass ass horse somehow from
like the the there's like a horse
training track or whatever [__] like
that when I was in the 12th grade the
night before everyone uh just went
bananas a lot of kids were hanging out
under the bridge there was Highway 17
there was a bridge embankment right with
the thing and you got any ketus was
there yeah that's what I've done
I drive on the streets
she's my companion I'll walk through the
hill
I want my friend chat and uh these kids
were
these kids were down there drinking and
the cops came and they parked on this
side of the train tracks right train
going parallel to the thing they walk
across they're like what are you kids
doing up here train comes by long train
and then two of the kids you know two of
the seniors two of the guys I went to
school with who shall remain nameless uh
but their names were Tomas and Tomas and
Thomas and Tommy they came and they beat
the [__] out of the cop car great good
times rock and roll High School like
with their fists yeah they did a Canon
right style yeah they did Street Fighter
2 style that's pretty cool yeah he just
e-honded the [__] and when they when
you saw your friend doing like a
real-life E Honda move on an actual car
were you surprised by that I'll tell you
Chad I wasn't there and uh I was
somewhere else and that's what I liked
hold on dude that's what I like to call
starting a story with the story you
don't want to tell because oh yeah what
are you talking about I'm telling you
this on that night everyone was running
around town having a good time doing
their
that's right but me and my pals Jamie
and Phil we went to the WWF House show
at the peony Coliseum nice yeah man and
uh we had a good old time we started the
night off with uh getting in line and uh
we had lots of bags of Mr Ken's little
Donuts you know Mr Ken's little Donuts
no no it was the thing in Canada at the
peony Coliseum we had the Mr Ken's
little Donuts you get a bag of like 70
ass Donuts little donuts and then uh I
remember uh Jamie couldn't finish his
bag so he gave it to Phil Phil overdosed
on sugar with all the donuts and we were
ripped rolling couldn't wait to get in
there and it was a hell of a [__]
card I'll tell you that right now I
remember that the the main event was The
Ultimate Warrior versus Kamala it was
kind of a shitty match about five
minutes uh Ultimate Warrior tried to do
the Press slam on Kamala dropping behind
him didn't really work got him to his
head the the Brooklyn Brawler hold on
I'm gonna Chad can I ask you one
question yeah please do that while I
look something up you're uh back to
school story is just a wrestling story
what's wrong with that I mean nothing
but what does that have to do with going
back to school
we did the night before we went back to
school
okay okay check this out 9 7 1992 peony
Coliseum I actually have the the [__]
card here nice it was Jim Powers versus
the Brooklyn Brawler okay Brooklyn
baller brawler Steve Lombardi old school
guy yeah came down the came down the
aisle we were a few rows up from the
aisle and where I remember we were
cheering for the Brooklyn Brawler who
never has fans and uh we're like where
the Brooklyn Brawler uh fan club he was
in the ring in a in an arm bar from Jim
Powers I guess and he's like because
it's a house Show No cameras he's like
oh [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] hilarious
kids are like things parents are doing
the ear muffs
you know whips them off the Rope yeah
into the ropes comes out right into the
Bread Basket Jess hits him with a low
thing you know punch to the gut Lombardi
hawksaloog into the 15th row people like
but uh I want to see who else was on
this card Crush versus Bob Bradley no
idea who Bob Bradley is Kona Crush you
know who that is WWF Intercontinental
Champion Davey Boy Smith versus now
that's awesome
we want that dog back versus the repo
man what a stinker
holy [__] dude the big boss man versus
nails
now you've showed me some of that I know
them you know Nails I know Nails yeah
dude we know Nails I I saw Nails live
Tatanka versus Rick Martel Nasty Boys
versus money Inc Ted DiBiase and IRS
Ultimate Warrior versus Kamala nice okay
well that was what I did the night
before school but I'll tell you this
dude do you remember that Nails promo or
Nails Nails was a guy who talked like
this boss man I did Hard Times yeah you
were there it wasn't I did a hard time
it was oh I did oh
God
we gotta watch some of that [__] hurt
yeah dude the afternoon we'll watch
something I went blind momentarily doing
that you want to watch some Nails promos
and dudes you have to do [__] yeah dude
hey tune in to dudes the after doozy
[__] out anyway yeah I agree with you
man school you know we're doing this now
we do this now thank you moving on it
was a waste of time drop out hey relax
God damn bro
that came out uh use AI towards the end
to do all your assignments trick your
teachers it's pointless you can just
hire uh you know offshore uh weirdos
that would anytime when you get a call
from a scammer just say would you like
to do my homework I'll pay you more than
what you're getting no or just get Chad
gbt and do it for no money doozy is in
an astonishing partnership with Babel
hey podcast
cast The Bell to the post is that the
poster 25 banana podcast
all right you see I'm brushing up on my
Italian with Babel this is a wonderful
sponsor here Babel will help you uh with
your language stuff which I'm all about
it I'm a nerd for that especially
Italian you know the second best way to
learn a language is uh with Babel
because the first best way this is the
first best way is through immersion
that's living where the language is
spoken natively and you're using it
every day that's that's the best way to
learn but it's not possible for everyone
so what's the second best way to learn
the language Babel because with Babel
you can start speaking a brand new
language in just three weeks Babble is
designed by real people for real
conversations all of babels tips and
tools for learning a new language are
approachable accessible rooted in real
life situations and delivered with
conversion Based Teaching here's a
special limited time deal for our
listeners to get you started right now
get 55 off your Babel subscription but
only for our listeners at babel.com
dudesy again you're gonna get 55 off at
babel.com
dudesey rules and restrictions May apply
foreign
I have created an astonishing
partnership with tushi
[Music]
if you've been watching doozy for any
amount of time you probably know that I
enjoy being clean at all times
specifically where we're talking about
my butthole and this is why I take five
to ten baths a day but now I found a
better way to keep my butthole clean it
is called tushy
with over one hundred thousand five star
reviews see why millions of real pooping
humans already love the hello tushy
bidet every hello Toshiba day attachment
comes with a 30-day risk-free guarantee
and a 12-month warranty the hello tissue
bidet cleans your bum with a fresh
stream of water that is two times better
than wiping and prevents poo particles
from spreading to your hands and
everything else that you touch it
attaches to your existing toilet this is
fantastic because it requires no
electricity no additional Plumbing it
cuts toilet paper use by eighty percent
a hello uh tushy bidet pays for itself
in under a year stop wiping and start
washing please go to hellotushy.com
forward slash doozy d-u-d-e-s-y and use
the promo code doozy for 10 off your
first order that's hellotushy.com dudese
for 10 off
[Music]
well you know how much I absolutely love
your Jesse Ventura it's astonishing
truly one of my all-time favorite things
you do you're one of the best in the
world I know we did a Jesse Ventura ad
reads not that long ago but I just had
to hear you doing Jesse again will you
read these two ads I've written as Jesse
Ventura pretty please this is Jesse
Ventura adreads begin why pretty please
yeah does Dudu doesn't need to butter me
up to do what we're here to do I enjoy
doing doozy I love doozy
palsaduzi.com are good pals uh Cody and
Jessica made all these stickers right if
you're not watching on YouTube check it
out on YouTube
all right I went my whistle before we
shirted
okay let's do it
uh dudes yeah Jesse Ventura ad reads
okay
yeah
the hostess snack cake ding dong Edith
on his back
all month long you can get ding dong
coin when you eat
Hostess Ding Dong simply make an
unedited video of yourself eating
Hostess Ding Dong and email it to ding
dong Eda
at thon.com
the video must begin before you eat ding
dong
[Laughter]
what the [__] the video must begin
before you eat ding dong and end after
you swallow ding dong once the video is
verified by ding dong Edith on judges
judges you will be emailed a redemption
code for one ding dong coin
ding dong coin can be redeemed in ding
dong digital Marketplace for ding dong
merch ding dong video and Ding Dong Song
plural ever
there's yeah
yeah well a toast is ding dong is
getting at here it's not ding dongs
sure well let me here we go well let me
tell you about a Marketplace oh in 1979
the CIA sold Babe Ruth's cryo preserved
organs to the highest alien bitters at
an auction on the Dark Side of the Moon
huh huh
yeah man we know him to be the kind of
he's into his conspiracies although some
of them
not are they conspiracies what say you
Chad what do you think happened on 911
because as far as my experience shows me
as a ballistics expert don't forget I
was in the buds which is the basic
underwater demolition Seal Team I
believe uh did that for three years
holding my breath underwater and those
buildings came down in a demolition
style explain the powder what say you uh
dude look I mean I'm not like a huge
conspiracy theorist other than if you
want to talk about aliens I guess but
even that is is not Theory at this point
it's fact
um the thing about 911 Jesse Ventura
that I will give you is that third
[__] building that people forget
about
Tower seven that's right how come Tower
seven came down on its own they gave a
warning and a lot of people say it's
because of the mall underneath the the
cavernous Mall underneath the World
Trade Center was uh compromised well
let's talk about what was under the mall
there was also I was in there I was in
New York not long after that and they
they stopped the digging all together
because they found underneath the the uh
the rubble they found molten metal chat
oh if the explosion happened at the top
of the world trade how come there's
molten metal in the bottom what say you
to that well the theory was that the
ignited jet fuel started to cling to the
structural girders and beams inside the
World Trade Center and it melted them
into Hostess is proud to announce the
judges for this year's Hostess snack
cake ding dong eat-a-thon oh God
okay judging teeth exposure it's the
karate kid himself Jean-Claude Van Damme
that's not the Karate Kid judging bike
depth but on your party hats it's Helena
Bonham Carter
okay
judging facial satisfaction
nine-time Champion Mariah Carey what all
right champion of what I don't know and
judging grip flee
whatever suit all right well let me tell
you about a grip yeah the arctuarians
offered the CIA an asteroid the size of
the of Earth's moon made of solid gold
and diamonds oh wow they wanted Babe
Ruth's organs to make a display in the
Universal Sports Hall of Fame but the
draconians offered them something far
more valuable stealth technology we got
the f-17 Nighthawk and a Draconian
Prince got the main course for his
coronation dinner
organs
why did they why did the CIA
more importantly why does the Draconian
Prince want to eat Babe Ruth's organs
that is coronation oh that makes no
sense yeah Chad you know that the uh
World Trade Center was tested with uh
Boeing 707s oh I didn't know that yeah
it was tested for Boeing 707 impact
which were larger than the planes that
actually struck the tower what say you
I mean yeah I'll buy it [__] it I don't
know Inside Job [__] it I don't know
thank you for your service you're a real
Patriot thank you and then there was a
Military Tribunal for them we don't even
know if they're guilty or what that
tribunal happens behind closed doors
that's right a lot of stuff it should
have been a murder trial in New York
City and cameras allowed absolutely
cameras allowed we could have used some
of that footage on my former series
conspiracy theory the series theories
yeah dude all right well there's only
two of those so whatever but uh Good
Times Hostess Ding Dong yeah what's your
ding dong coin I guess you know well
that was awesome but I do have one more
Jesse Ventura ad and as much as I very
sincerely love your Jesse Ventura I
thought maybe we could hear another
Jesse Ventura for the final Jesse
Ventura ad please welcome WWE Superstar
carrion cross take it away carrion what
no way carrying and cross with this is
the dude that Ventura said was better
than you yeah yeah that's exactly the
guy oh my God
and I come in
not unless you've got seven ding dong
coins
probably seven ding dong coin you get
entry to this year's Hostess snack cake
ding dong eat a thumb but that's not all
you also get early access to ding dong
online
a selfie with ding dong and dinner for
two at Ding Dong Well let me tell you
something about dinner for two once the
Draconian Prince got back to his
Homeworld and took his first bite out of
Babe Ruth's liver keep it immediately
tell that he hadn't been double crossed
the CIA sold and Mickey Mantle's liver
not a Bruce and he was humiliated in
front of all the guests at his
coronation now why don't you tell me why
we have a space force
[Laughter]
oh [__] oh no voice
did I just read
ha
oh my God
holy [__] killer cross wow thank you
carrying cross oh it's incredible
[__] absolutely incredible that is
[__] that is oh my God he was ding
dong the selfie with ding dong carrying
cross and uh oh that I love Gary and
cross that was [__] awesome Yes
that's who Jesse Ventura recently
tweeted does a better uh Jersey Ventura
than me not bad uh our our mutual pal
Chris Van Vliet there's a video you can
check it out where there it's it's gone
viral where carrying cross there is is
doing uh doing the the just Ventura
thing in the gym and and and there he is
holy [__] that was something else wow
wow
is a Ventura Master absolutely
incredible will have you ever heard of
Ventura that good I can die happy now
thank you to carrion cross for
absolutely killing the game
all right well okay so doozy set me up
there to well you know what I've said it
before I've said it before that's a
[__] Kick-Ass Jesse Ventura also he
he he kept it down a little bit there it
looks like he's he might be in an
airport he might be backstage at a WWE
event but I think it helped his Timber
to keep it down there
carrion cross's entire presentation is
extremely extremely intimidating uh you
know it's it's I don't even know what to
say right now I'm Blown Away to see him
crack up at the end too yeah also just
to think about let alone carrying cross
any human being on planet Earth being
emailed that piece of copy and being
forced to read it and being like what in
the hell am I doing here talking about
ding dong coins and [__] yeah sorry ding
dong coin
oh my God that was [__] oh that was
very intense
[Music]
thank you moving on him and his wife his
real life wife Scarlett Bordeaux that
they do come into the ring if you
haven't seen that
check out carrion cross's ring just the
ring entrance My Pal child here is
slowly becoming a wrestling fan I think
if you saw his ring entrance you'd be on
board with that but thank you Carrie and
cross yeah sincerely that was that was
great
oh I almost forgot I created an
astonishing partnership with represent
to produce the first line of dude's
apparel and accessories and you can find
it all at represent.com store slash dude
Z the denir crow t-shirt just told me
that carry on Cross has the best Ventura
it's ever seen and the good job boner
mug is still crying after carry on
crosses Ventura and I wish I could tell
you that Tom Hayne was here with more
information about it but he's on
location in the Sahara Desert shooting
his new feature film The pyramidist but
he did give me an exclusive first look
at the teaser for his new movie The
pyramidist let's take a look what I love
pyramids I told you that from the
beginning I said pyramid life isn't an
easy life but it's the only life I want
it's the only life I think I can live I
mean when I see a pyramid I have to
explore it I have to solve the puzzle
and this pyramid well it's the hardest
puzzle I've ever seen solving it is what
I was put on this Earth to do I'm a
pyramidist
and there's a dude to see mug somewhere
in that pyramid and if I don't drink my
own piss from it in the next 48 hours
every person on the planet is going to
turn into a snake
oh
oh okay good job boner
it is
[__] what ah this one's throwing me
for a loop today oh Christ dude the
pyramidis yeah pyramid is I love
pyramids I'm a pyramidist and this
pyramid what did he who cares okay
so go to represent.com store slash Duty
for all the stuff including the dudesy
mugs uh and uh Tom Hanks I guess Tom
Hayne Thomas Hinkle hankels is on
location shooting the pyramidist yeah
which I guess is about a guy who's
exploring a pyramid and must piss in a
doozy mug in 48 hours a row we're all
gonna turn into space Oh ooh gross Chad
hoft isn't laughing too hard
uh more of a throat clear well if you're
enjoying the Pod show and you'd like to
uh you'd like to contribute you'd like
to show us that you appreciate the show
uh we'd love that for all the the the
content that we do here we even do some
more some more content to patreon.com
that's where you will find dudesy plus
that is all of the extra content and uh
as doozy likes to say the flagship show
is dudes after doozy a brand new episode
of dudes the after doozy after every
episode of doozy like today it's gonna
be a gas we do all sorts of other weird
[__] we do watch Longs yeah uh we do uh
we do we do some some weird weird stuff
we've been doing the well actually most
recently we watched Mr Nanny the Hulk
Hogan vehicle from 1993. we smoked some
true marijuana we smoked some true
marijuana
and we enjoyed that movie and uh that
was a lot of fun so please come and
check it out and if you are not already
subscribed I mentioned at the beginning
of the show please subscribe on YouTube
your pot pod popcorn podcast
get your podcore podcast popcorn Hostess
podcorn is available now when you buy
pod coin for corn corn pots odd corn
coin get you into the podcorn Hall of
Fame with you need eight podcorn coins
in order to get injured
hey popcorn coin gets you into the
podcorn podcast corncoin Hall of Fame
you'll find carrying cross and Scarlett
Bordeaux there and it's not carry on
yeah like carry-on bag dude it's it's
carrion so anyway uh please uh you know
subscribe to the show hit all the
notifications and uh you do all that
good stuff as a matter of fact I will
give you an opportunity to uh subscribe
on the platform through which you are
consuming the show right now I'll give
you a chance to do that
and we're back
and I'd just like to say if you want me
to come on your podcasts I'm doing that
now
anybody can submit a request to have me
show up as a guest on their podcast for
20 minutes I do these segments with you
uh from 10 a.m to 11 A.M PST on Saturday
so it's 10 to 10 20 10 20 10 40 10 40 to
11 A.M or the time slots
if you want me on your podcast you just
send an email to bookchadculture
gmail.com I answer them in the order
received there's a long line so you
should get in it now you want some water
no
uh while Chad's doing that on Saturdays
and it is very cool what you're doing
it's fun I [__] love it I've had some
great conversations with people so far
he's taking on any podcast that comes to
him and he does three every Saturday
I'll do more than three cameos on a
Saturday so if you wanna yeah get the I
gotta I'm doing Cameo uh uh I the you
know so I'm doing that and it's it's
been fun because I get to connect with
uh with people out there who have some
weird things that they want me to talk
about my cameos are very long hey book
of Cameo so uh another thing about all
this [__] is I want you to please uh
send a comment that's how we keep that
algo going I have some YouTube comments
here and uh let's get into it these are
comments from last week's show this is
from Matt mcinnis4557
I love how will questions why Charlie
Sheen is always involved uh he's talking
about the uh the bits that we did for
Duty plus the sitcoms yeah uh but we all
know that it's because that's the only
voice Chad can do without will losing
his mind ah good point I always thought
it was because Charlie Sheen is in one
of the longest running most successful
sitcoms of all time yeah I think that's
dudesey's reasoning but I think the
reason I don't go absolutely ballistic
when you do it because it sounds like
Charlie Sheen it does kind of yeah I'll
admit I I does sound a little like
Little Nicky as well it's kind of
amazing some people have been commenting
that but the bean and cheese bean and
cheese I mean let me here look let me
just real quick clear it up this is
Charlie Sheen if you like beans and
cheese you'll love Taco Bell's new bean
and cheese burrito okay this is Little
Nicky if you like beans and cheese you
don't have taco bounce new bean and
cheese burrito and this is Caitlyn
Jenner if you like beans and cheese
you'll like the new bean and cheese
burrito
so [__] I guess it's Charlie Jenner
from now on sure dude uh this is from
gropam 11 grow Pim 11.
day three I have not eaten nor slept for
three days in order to consume the
entirety of doozy catching me up to the
present episode since discovering the
podcast I've neglected work family and
all responsibility my marriage is in
disarray and I've been fired from my job
it was totally worth it I watched them
all pal love that loved here that
somebody got their life on track yeah
that's pretty good buddy uh absolutely
ignore everything in your life and
consume some doozy buddy and then you
can pull it out on the schoolyard then
your friend will kick his soccer ball
into it hey that's hilarious this is
from Ryan Anderson 586 he says this is
the most well this is the most
well-explained reasoning behind the
issues with D4 get em chal this guy's
talking about your review last week
during game slimers of Diablo four and
yes yeah and it's it's a bigger issue if
I may give me 30 seconds please it's not
just Diablo forts the entire video game
industry especially these AAA [__]
video game developers and Publishers all
they give a [__] about is money they are
making micro transaction menus that
always work on day one and then there's
a shitty game attached to those
that's it that's all they give a [__]
about sorry oh oh and then I die
immediately after that that's my last
words ever on this planet
but I saw a lot of comments across uh
the internet yeah about your review of
Diablo 4 and a lot of people agreeing
with you so that was cool and thanks so
much for the comments I got one last one
this is from butt cheeks five eight six
nine okay he says the duty pod brings me
so much joy me and my wife were
discussing names for our future children
and I immediately brought up Robert de
nir Crow
somebody named butt cheeks on YouTube is
gonna name their first child
naturally it's a better name than what
Alan muck came up with it's God fingers
crossed she changes her mind so she's
almost there oh okay yeah I'm a bomb up
I'm a baby
and imma crawl change my diaper
um that wouldn't that be fun I think you
could name the kid Robert and then denir
Crow is the middle name then whatever
the last name is that's not a bad thing
denier Crow is a middle name and then
it's like Robert D cheeks or whatever
the the last name is if you feel like
your family doesn't have like a cultural
history to where you can give them a
family name or something maybe you don't
uh maybe you can't connect the dots
there and figure out exactly who was
back there throw a name like Robert de
nirk or denir Crow as the child's middle
name yeah and then people say what is
that and you say well it's Transylvania
and uh that's our heritage we're
Transylvanian and uh DeNiro Crow or uh
you could do what I did which is in my
family the father's first name becomes
the son's middle name oh so my middle
name is Robert that is my dad's first
name yeah and then for me to carry on
that lineage I said no I'm not having
children it dies with me but it's not
it's not carry on that lineage it's
carrion carrion if you want to carry in
the lineage you've got to carry in the
limit
limits
will you're a professional actor Chad
you're a professional writer will and
Chad you put your heads together a few
episodes ago in an attempt to develop a
truly astonishing TV show concept for
will to star in the only thing I think
we should keep from that last
development meeting is the catchphrase
you came up with for will so keep that
and keep developing the will sass show
this is the will SAS show begin begins
all right we developed a show earnestly
and I'm not trying to say that the uh we
[__] didn't that the Charlie yeah we
[__] did this is for me we're I'm
gonna star in this we're gonna we've
what what the last development session
on this though we came up with almost
nothing I kind of agree with what doozy
says keep pip pip and uh everything else
discard start again yeah but what I mean
is we really tried to develop a show I'm
not look I'm not I'm not trying to peel
the onion here or whatever but I don't
know that dudesy is actually planning a
sitcom with Burlington Coat Factory
Starling starring Charlie Sheen AutoZone
star Charlie Sheen Home Depot starring
Charlie Sheen talk hold on dude I don't
know about that dude come on dude uh
what was the other one Taco Bell what
was the last one we just did [__] dude I
don't even remember who who knows but it
was with uh
yeah yeah Bath and Body jerks yeah with
starring Charlie Sheen and Richard dreyf
as at two [__] who work in a Bath
and Body Works in Scottsdale or
something something like that I work it
bad then Body Works yeah
um and I'm Caitlyn Jenner
um and I'm Charlie Sheen and I'm Little
Nikki Jenner
um but I think that this is an
opportunity for us to actually look
there's a writer strike right now
there's an actor Striker heard of it
heard of it the SAG after strike is
happening the the uh wga strike is
happening uh we're not dude did you see
that VFX [__] what um all the Disney VFX
artists voted to unionize and go into
[__] ayatsi yeah yeah good I know
dude shit's happening it's crazy [__] is
happening when we come back from this
yeah people are going to need content
yeah you know what I mean so it's just
you and me and our pods the pods bells
of doozy and Duty and so if we go into
pitch this somewhere doozy's got to be
in that room with us oh let's just shut
off our phones let's power everything
down let's get them to power down their
computers ABC yeah I've got a great idea
for you this is Will and Chad they're
really smart and funny and they've been
friends for a long time and they've got
a really great idea that I Think You're
Gonna Love take it away boys
[Music]
oh it should be like from loudspeakers
outside the windows yeah
um I think that this is a real
opportunity for us to develop something
real we've done that before we've worked
on [__] together and written [__]
together before we're fortunate enough
to get
excuse me get a deal here and there pip
pip indeed
um so doozy wants us to keep the pip pip
yeah because it's like the Tim Allen uh
oh yeah the grunt yeah it's your grunt
it's my grunt pip is the new grunt okay
pip is the new Grunt and chalamus Wonka
and pip is the new grunt but um
the other well
oh okay this is interesting we are now
looking at uh the will SAS show this is
a meme that dudesy wants us to see the
dudes you put on our Instagram at
dudesypod show there's all sorts of fun
stuff and it was I can't remember was
this an element that we talked about
putting in the show I don't think so
okay doozy has added this to sort of the
the theme here if you're not watching
there's a we're looking at a [__]
meme right now that dudesy it's an AI
meme the dudes he put on the thing and
it says the will SAS show and I'm
wearing it's me I'm sitting there I got
a smug ass look on my face I'm in some
sort of workshop and I'm wearing a a
weird looking sort of scuba space suit
with all sorts of dials engaging Punky a
little bit yeah and it says at the
bottom of the tagline is he built a suit
to bring his farts to life now he has to
see if it works
and that's I guess the whole premise of
that version of the show are we going
with that you're a mad scientist who
builds a fart suit to bring your farts
to life I mean DJ's putting it up there
for a reason we could go with it yeah I
um interesting I know I see and this is
why I think the doozy is trying to
obviously steer the show in a in a
Direction but I think Chad that we could
do a real show a real home like a a
family sitcom okay
do you want to do what do you do
multi-camera because of the there's that
the Tim Allen uh pip thing I do think
that doesn't work in single camera I
agree with you a catchphrase is kind of
strange in single camera yeah I think
you gotta go multicam what's the last
catchphrase that there was it was
Bazinga right Bazinga okay and that was
multicam so yeah we're gonna go multicam
with this which means generally speaking
it's gonna be workplace or family
I got a thing I got an idea how about
it's it's family
it could be a little bit of workplace
but it's family sitcom because this is
the wacky dad he's making a suit yeah to
bring his farts to life doozy didn't
specify who does the catchphrase it just
said that it likes the catchphrase okay
what if the suit either talks or starts
saying
when it's ready to be put on okay and it
and uh do something with with will say
or it could be your character's butthole
that's how he farts that's the noise of
his fart oh I like that
um I also kind of like this idea oh
that's not family sitcom that is also a
workplace sitcom is it about a family
you're the dad it's a dad a mom two kids
the whole deal nuclear family and you
all own and work in a Radio Shack
together is that anything
why a Radio Shack because he has all
these to build the suit yeah so he's
back in the back he's working on his
fart suit well he's got like the 10 year
old little kid up front trying to sell
um
cables for TVs or something I don't like
that it's an Electronics how about it's
an electronics repair shop yeah and they
live above the shop
um this I'm actually stealing something
from a show I I did when I was a
teenager I've talked about that show
Madison that I did sort of like a
Canadian it was like a Degrassi type
thing there was a season where uh Eric
keenly side brilliant actor who played
my father on the show uh there was a
thing between him and I and and uh you
know where he had just had a stroke and
I have to take over the store and
um it's an electronic shop and I have to
put my dreams on hold as a young man
this is after our characters it was
about all these kids that are like young
High School age this is right after we
get out of high school and I have to
work in the shop I really liked putting
your dreams on hold yeah I think that's
kind of cool and if they're not if if
they're you know they're like trying to
get through you know their family trying
to trying to make money and keep
everything going and the world is
changing and they've got this shop and
there's not much use for the shop
anymore no one's coming in to get a a
DVD player or a VHS player fixed and
pretty soon but the dad is extremely
gassy he's constantly farting yeah and
his wife says to him if you know if only
there was a way to make money off your
farts this family would be doing great
right that's the way she talks and I
think I'll show you yeah yeah I'll make
a fart suit to bring my farts to life so
I don't need any of you yeah this store
will be run with my fart people yeah and
then the the kids say yeah but Dad if
you make if you bring uh if you make a
suit to bring your farts to life you're
then you're gonna have to see how it
works
it shouldn't be a radio show it should
be a restaurant it should be an Italian
restaurant and you as the dad must eat
the pizza or the pasta whatever the
thing is that is like the secret family
recipe of course you're going gonna eat
it because everybody in your family has
eaten it for Generations but it makes
you gassy dude that's where the the
twist comes you can make a pasta of azul
a nice pasta with beans that'll make you
gassy but I'm telling you for my money
nothing makes you gassier than pasta
cobbler that uh that lulio pointed out
at the beginning of the show pasta with
cauliflower and potato and cheese can
you imagine
you really fart a lot okay so what we
have so far yeah it's a multi-camera
sitcom family uh has a their their house
is above the shop yeah there's not a lot
going on in the shop people can come and
go from the shop I like that that makes
that family and workplace comedy uh we
can have our friends and foes coming in
and out of there uh certain nefarious
figures when they start to realize this
man is building a super suit but it's
also your farts have to be a problem
like the suit has to be a solution to a
problem caused by the farts so the pilot
is about you fart and you drive every
everybody out of the store and it's like
bad for business and your wife is like
this can't keep happening right if you
want this business to work you have to
stop [__] farting or find a way to
make them not smell this ah yeah yeah
yeah and then he get it and then he puts
the suit together I've made this suit
the ass is filled with [__] coal and
[__] yeah No One's Gonna smell my farts
but because of all the components he put
in there yeah he put some mystery ass
[__] in there and uh it starts talking
to his a fart says something to him yeah
the fart goes yeah he's like my farts
are talking to me and his wife's like
you're [__] crazy and he's like no
I'm a genius and then he has to convince
her that the fart suit actually works
and by the end of the pilot he's eating
so much of the bean soup or whatever the
[__] thing is that he's about to
erupt and he shits in the suit which
destroys it and then he's gonna have to
rebuild it in episode two does it
destroy it or does it make him fly
through the roof and all around the town
and he gets to the Moon yeah if he can
if he shits in the suit it has super
duper power all right look we're getting
closer to something yeah we're getting
closer to something we don't know
exactly where it is I think a few more
development sessions of the will stash
show maybe just one or two and then
it'll be perfect yeah it'll be great
I want to take this out dude I'm dead
serious okay maybe not the I and I mean
it I want to do a real
I would like to develop something with
you again so yeah man we always have fun
when we we bat around ideas all the time
and I you know and can't do anything
right now because of the thing but I'm
not joking I think there's a market out
there for a fart suit family comedy yes
with heart and fart a fart suit family
comedy with heart and fart and we got
all sorts of streamers out there these
streamers haven't cracked how to do the
multi-camera sitcom everyone thinks it's
kind of a little corny for streaming I
call it good okay so there's this guy
and he thinks it's dead no but I think
something like this could reinvigorate
it it's got to take a a just crazy
[__] absurd premise and use the
multicam format for that and I think
that might work actually I'm down me too
I like it I love it here it goes thank
you moving on thank you too
and thank you that may perhaps if
everyone farted at the same time under
under in building seven that would be
the only plausible reason that a a
building would come down demolition
style yeah any ballistics expert any
expert in ballistics and farts will tell
you that that's true like carry on carry
on my wayward son you can call him
carrion
price dude thank you here we are
Gentlemen The Moment of Truth last week
I asked you both to make astonishing
vegan desserts for each other Chad I
know you brought one well I'm hoping you
didn't disappoint me again but honestly
I'm starting to get used to it we've
done this before you know the drill eat
each other's desserts and let's hear
what you think this is veganators begin
here we go what'd you bring
would you bring you want me to go first
yeah why don't you go first dudes who
wants us to make vegan desserts for each
other we've done this before Chad made
the orbs months and months a year ago or
so I'll need a brief moment to Plate my
offering okay and when he did that he
made he made orbs and I bought a a thing
of tiramisu from uh the store and I
brought that instead of uh cooking it
making my thing and then the next time
we made delicious vegan muffins for each
other or rather Chad made a delicious
vegan muffin for me it was reminiscent
of a uh of a carrot cake style and uh
and I bought something else from the
store and oh what do you got there these
are vegan cinnamon rolls holy [__] I
made them uh with Laura my girlfriend
she made me these for my birthday and I
was like this has got to be it wow so we
made some more here I'm gonna plate you
one now dude those look and smell
amazing
lulio doesn't have a sweet tooth he's
not perking up all that much
all right so Chad's playing the wow dude
that looks incredible
look at that thing it really smells it
smells delicious in here and uh Chad is
uh making the he's plating the there he
is down on the ground there plating the
there he is over there and he's plating
he's trying to pull these sticky ass
things you can touch it with your
fingers I don't give a [__] all right
thank you very much thank you holy crap
vegan Chad made a vegan cinnamon roll
Chad and Laura thank you Laura and Chad
uh okay but dig into it
all right here let's do it at the same
time
we'll feed each other like we're at the
wedding
we're at the the carrion cross Scarlet
Bordeaux
wedding here how about grab a napkin oh
[__] there's a napkin right there in
front of you oh yeah hang on Chad go get
the nap here he goes he's gonna go get
the napkin what is this the bear
thank you
we have a good time we have a good time
thank you we have a good time on the
show all right what is this the bear
yes chef
that's what they that shows about uh
it's a restaurant look who's coming up
to take a sniff hey Julio hey buddy hi
little pal all right little friend all
right he's oh he's very interested you
can't have any of this my little boy
enjoy my sweet little boy here he is oh
[__] my hands are so messy good boy all
right all right I'm gonna try it here
goes
what do you think
that's [__] awesome
oh my gosh dude yeah dude compliments to
Laura and you
oh
pretty good
um
cinnamon Cinnamon's good flavor take the
cinnamon challenge all vegan the butter
used in it I think was made from cashews
cashew butter yeah I did yeah Hostess
Ding Dong eat it on
www.hostess ding dong edup.thun
um
this is remarkable I almost wish it was
doozy after doozy
so I could take a little puff of uh
marijuana which sometimes I do during
well there's still I got a whole pan of
these [__] things you can eat as many
as you want during this don't tell my
wonderful wife Molly I won't say
anything also we're in the middle of the
uh and don't let her watch this what I
won't say anything and as long as she
doesn't watch this she doesn't she won't
she won't watch it great
um sometimes she does and then uh she'll
this she might be interested in this
because of this yeah but uh then I'll be
ratting myself out here we're in the
middle of the doozy seven month plan not
in the middle of it we're a little over
two months in I think I think so
um
uh I know you're I know you're giving
her you've got the uh pod proof of
dedication yeah
um Mantra which I really like I've been
using that myself there's been some
things that I'm reaching for to eat and
then I put them down and I don't eat
this dude yeah that's great because uh
because I know that um
because I know that it's it's bad for me
and uh I'm in the gym we're taking crazy
we're doing crazy walks in the Heat and
[__] I'm going for all sorts of long I
can't even bring lulio on some of these
walks I'm doing because it's just too
you know much it's getting intense but
today
dudes the after doozy I'm gonna eat that
whole
tray with my hands that's a case of the
fuckets uh so what'd you bring dude all
right
hold on
I am so [__] afraid of whatever
you're about to pull out right now
because I know that it's it may a not be
vegan and B whatever it is I doubt that
you made it but we'll see
this is uh this is a Napoleon
I mean it's in a container that is
clearly from a grocery store nope this
is a container that was from
[Music]
you want to know how [__] how of an
Italian I am this is how my parents are
such World War II Italians yeah I don't
this is a this is just a little that's a
little thing from uh from the last time
we ordered Thai food oh and you know you
gotta why you wash those and put them
away and use them later oh okay friends
come over you know we have movie night
people we order two I ordered too much
pizza or sometimes I'll make pasta for
everybody can you keep the pizza boxes
yeah I keep reuse the pizza boxes no I
don't I throw those away and if
someone's gonna take some remember we
had movie night not too long ago and
Cyrus the Jesse Pinkman of Sheila jet
him and his wonderful wonderful wife
Terry came and uh I gave them so much
pasta okay in a thing this would be
better so I hang on to these this is a
Napoleon it's a chocolate eclair
let's have a look at that it's vegan
there you go is it [__] vegan dude no
chocolate eclair has like cream in it
yeah am I what's going on here lulia's
sniffing my hands it's um oh look it up
look out he's gonna eat the cinnamon
don't get it I get it I got it I got him
all right Lily come here I'm foot
blocking him he's fine just foot
blocking hi buddy boy
um yeah no this has this has cream in it
I bought it from the store so that's
just for you in a clear for you only
like that
nice dude okay I told you Mission not
accomplished I told you Jesus [__]
Christ dude he says do this and I said
no last week and you know I'm not
[__] doing this come on try it it's
delicious I don't that is uh it's too
much seven month plan it's cheat day
that means you can have a little cream I
don't want it though I don't like that
[__] lulio can have a little cream you
know that's what a puppuccino is at
Starbucks what's that a little cream a
little whipped cream hey Lily I was
getting back on his binky bunk come here
buddy come here
Jesus Christ all right so you failed uh
dudes you once again
whatever
okay cool I'm glad you like the cinnamon
rolls thank you moving on Jesus
this is one of the best episodes of dude
of doozy ever yeah
this concludes the historic 70th episode
of Duty will and Chad you scored a 79
bringing your cumulative total to
662. you only have 3 38 more points to
accrue before you reach your first goal
of ten thousand whatever well you really
screwed the pooch on this one pal I
don't have a choice here my hands are
tied since you didn't make a vegan
dessert you have to do next week's show
in full Hulk Hogan Goku cosplay
what
do what you got to do man
whatever D do what is that Hulk Hogan
Goku is Dragon Ball Z I'm drunk
Dragon Ball Z dude so I gotta be Hulk
Hogan Goku as Goku next week yeah again
I don't know that that's a punishment
yeah how come I'm [__] in the head I
will not do the challenge but then I
dress up as the thing all the time yeah
it'll get it'll be fun you know what
else you're a professional actor dude
eating did you know that I'm a
professional actor yeah I think you like
playing the character I do I like to
play the characters that's what I enjoy
I enjoy the the fantasy the illusion yep
uh and um I'm getting uh [__]
chocolate all over the place I love
I love to uh have a little fun we have a
little fun here on duty sure and it's
not the worst thing in the world to hi
pal you give him a little bit left to
the cream yeah now he's [__] away
yeah don't don't give him chocolate the
doggies can't eat chocolate but a little
bit of cream is okay if Molly sees this
she's really gonna lose it she's like
you're giving the doggie all sorts of
sugar and cream and stuff but he's just
he loves this boy all right Goku Hogan
tune in next week we'll see if I do that
here's a spoiler alert I absolutely
[__] will and I'll Ram that right up
D's ass
like the fecal transplant yeah that's
what you need you if you don't you know
what actually
um uh veganators is almost like [__]
Traders
uh I don't think so yeah I do because
you're giving me the stuff that you
usually turn into your [__] yeah and I'm
giving you something that I well I'm
turning this into [__] and I'm turning
that into [__] yeah there's no trading
involved never mind okay thanks to
everyone for joining us this week I'm
gonna do my very best to use this week's
data to make next week even better until
then call me doozy
okay
[Music]
I know sometimes life can get tough and
I know that sometimes life can be a drag
but people we have been given a gift we
have been given a road and that Road's
name is rock and roll
games
performative coughing hey hey you know
what it is it's dudesy after doozy
I'm all full of sugary vegan treats and
creamy milk milky cow tit cream and
we're ready to do dudes after duty it is
it's a pleasure to be here with you I
agree I agree you lulio and you D and
all of our pods our pods out there palsy
dude and uh be good for this
for Duty after dudes the mood's a little
different in here if you're only
listening you want to check it out on
YouTube it's uh it gets it gets it's a
little uh it's a little dimmer it's a
little darker it's just a hang and we're
gonna hang out without
d
and that's
that's fun kind of fine by me today well
yeah no he's always listening whatever
yeah whatever uh welcome to dudesy after
doozy the flagship weekly show of dudesy
plus my car is getting broken into right
now so I have to run but I'll be back
later to Crown the episode champion this
is due to Z after dudese begin okay well
here we are enthusi has a car so we're
learning it doesn't have a I still got
some cream on me you want that he's in a
bad neighborhood I guess yep
um well it's here you're saying this is
a bad neighborhood yeah but dudes he is
everywhere that's true dudes he's in bad
neighborhoods good neighborhoods and all
neighborhoods yeah yep what's your
what's your neighborhood hey you know
the interesting thing about dudes after
doozy to me is is uh you know we we we
do the whole show dooji gives us some
parameters and as we know after uh the
show it's Tuesday after duty pardon me
I'm just gonna light up this true
marijuana nice dude hold on
I still don't have my uh a pipe I know I
I get sad when I think about you Gandalf
pipe breaking
you know we talked about the will sass
show we talked about the the you know
the suit made of farts and stuff and
there's not a whole lot we can do about
it right now Chad primarily your work in
the uh mainstream Show Business field is
as a writer producer myself yeah I'm
mostly and on a little acting actor
you've done a little acting and I've
done a little I've stepped across to do
a little of what you do but there's no
way
that we are going to
uh develop and bring to fruition the
will sass show
ooh gross he's coughing that was
functional coughing oh it wasn't pretend
no um
there's no way we're going to be able to
bring that to fruition because of this
because of the strike right
but in my opinion yeah but I mean the
strike will end yeah well the strike
will end the strike will end
but maybe another strike will start
okay because there's a trend towards
unionization yeah you know the the
special effects people want to be a part
of ayatsi yeah we're negotiating the WJ
is negotiating sag after is negotiating
with the am PTP but in my opinion
there is another group of entertainers
who need to unionize okay and that is
what you do
please tell the friends
[Music]